this video is made possible by maro maro
is the new revolutionary platform for
NEET PT aims P GI and d NP exams with
our 640 hours of recorded video lectures
and more than 28,000 highly selected
MCQs on all undergraduate medical
subjects marrow focuses on concept based
learning which is essential to perform
better in the PG entrance exams marrow
has interactive test series with subject
wise tests mini tests grand test series
with image based questions from
important and recent trends in medical
field marrow test series simulates the
real need PT exam with high probability
and secures giving you the extra edge
download for free now and B exam ready
links in the description below in this
video we will learn about the process of
translation translation is the second
step in gene expression gene expression
is the process by which information
stored in your DNA in the form of genes
is used in the synthesis of functional
gene products these gene products are
mainly proteins which have numerous
functions in your cells like repair and
maintenance of cell's energy synthesis
and enzymatic actions on biochemical
reactions gene expression essentially
occurs in two steps it begins in the
nucleus with the process of
transcription in which the information
on the DNA is copied into a RNA this RNA
is known as the messenger RNA or the
mRNA since the main job of this RNA is
to carry this information or message
outside the nucleus and use it to
perform the second step of gene
expression known as translation in
translation the message stored on the
mRNA is decoded in a ribosome to produce
a specific amino acid chain or
polypeptide make sure to watch the video
on the first step of gene expression the
transcription for a better understanding
of the complete topic also make sure to
watch the videos on structure of nucleic
acids and DNA as we will help you to
utilize this video in a much better way
all the links are in the description
below let's first have a brief look onto
what are the structures in the cell that
make the process of translation possible
besides the messenger RNA translation
also requires another type of our
known as the transfer RNA or the tRNA
ribosomes are dedicated cellular
machineries that make this whole process
possible the ribosomes that read the
message on the mRNA and the tRNA
transfers individual amino acids to the
ribosome according to the sequence of
base pairs on the mRNA these amino acids
are then joined together by bonds to
form a protein so the process of
translation occurs in three basic steps
first step is known as initiation in
which the ribosome assembles around the
target mRNA in the second step known as
elongation the tRNA transfers amino
acids to the ribosome which are joined
together to form a polypeptide chain in
the last step known as termination the
ribosomes release the polypeptide when
it reads a stop signal on the mRNA don't
worry if you don't understand these
steps yet we will look at the details of
this process in just a bit that will
help you to understand this complex
cellular process now let's look at where
this process takes place in the cell
it's slightly different for eukaryotes
and prokaryotes in prokaryotes the
translation takes place in the cytoplasm
in eukaryotes the translation occurs in
the cytoplasm or across the membrane of
the endoplasmic reticulum what happens
is that when the ribosomes bind to the
mRNA this whole complex then attaches to
the endoplasmic reticulum the new
protein is synthesized and released into
the endoplasmic reticulum this protein
can be stored inside the endoplasmic
reticulum or released in the future or
it can also be secreted immediately
before going into the details of process
of translation it's important to learn
about a few concepts the main machine
which plays a central role in
translation is ribosome ribosomes are
complex molecular structures found
inside all living cells and they act as
a site for protein synthesis the
ribosomes essentially consists of two
major components a small subunit and a
large subunit the unit of measurement
used to describe the ribosomal subunits
is the Swedberg unit which is a measure
of the rate of sedimentation in
centrifugation rather than size in
eukaryotic ribosomes the smaller subunit
is 40 s and the larger subunit
sixty years when they join they are
denoted as ATS these subunits lies
separately in the cytoplasm until they
need to come together for translation
these subunits have different jobs as
well the small subunit reads the mRNA
whereas the large subunit joins the
minor acids to form a polypeptide chain
now assuming you have watched the videos
on structure of nucleic acids and DNA
you know that the information of the
genetic code is stored in the form of
base pairs with four main bases adenine
guanine cytosine and thymine in RNA we
have uracil in place of thymine now the
cornerstone to understand the process of
translation is to understand what is a
codon a codon is basically a sequence of
three DNA or RNA bases when a mRNA goes
inside a ribosome the ribosome does not
read individual bases but rather these
sequences of three bases which are known
as codons each of these sequences of
three base pairs corresponds to a
specific amino acid
for example if three uracil bases are in
sequence which means the code will be
uuu the ribosome will read this code and
amino acid that is used will be
phenylalanine similarly if the core is
UCC the amino acid that will be used is
serene and so on
the codon Aug codes for the methionine
and is also the start codon which
signals the ribosome to start
synthesizing the protein similarly we
have three special codons which signal
the ribosome to stop synthesizing the
protein these are you AG UAA and UGA
these are known as stop codons and when
the ribosome read these they know that
the protein is now complete and their
job is done now let's get into the
details of translation so the first step
in translation is known as initiation
this is a transfer RNA or tRNA which has
an amino acid methionine bound to it
this tRNA attaches to the smaller
subunit of ribosome and when it
encounters a mRNA it starts reading the
code on the mRNA from its 5 prime end as
soon as a tRNA ribosome finds the start
signal the Aug codon it immediately
binds to the larger subunit to form the
complete ribosome and the protein
synthesis is initiated the next step in
the process is elongation elongation is
when the polypeptide chain gets longer
in the larger subunit of ribosome we
have three slots or sites which are
named as e P and a I'll explain these
sites with a simple concept like I told
you the first tRNA to attach to this
mRNA complex is a tRNA with amino acid
methionine this tRNA occupies the p side
P stands for peptidyl side now on each
side of the p side we have two more
sites the E and the a side and here is
the mRNA in the smaller subunit now what
happens is the a site receives the next
tRNA which matches the codon next in the
sequence if you zoom in we can see that
the first codon is the start codon the
Aug 2 which the trna attached will have
the amino acid methionine now if the
next codon is you au the trna attached
to the a site will have amino acid
tyrosine so this tRNA is now occupying
the a site now we know the main job of
translation is to form a protein which
is essentially a chain of a minor
sets so what we need next is to form a
bond between the amino acid on the tRNA
in the p-site and the amino acid on the
tRNA in the airside after this the tRNA
in the p-site loses its amino acid and
becomes empty out of which the ribosome
moves and now you can see that the tRNA
in the p-site moves to the east side
which is the exit site and the tRNA in
the air site moves into the p-site the a
site thus becomes empty and ready to
receive the next tRNA so the p site
always holds the growing polypeptide
chain this process is repeated again for
example if the next code is c gu the
tRNA that will enter the a site will
have the amino acid arginine attached to
it next the bond will form between the
small polypeptide chain and amino acid
on the tRNA in the a site again this
tRNA becomes empty and the mRNA moves
again repeating the whole process until
we get a polypeptide chain of desired
length the next step in the process is
known as the termination the ribosomes
must have a way to know where to stop so
that we get a final protein of desired
number of amino acids this is possible
because the mRNA actually contains stop
signals which is known as the stop codon
when the ribosome reads any of the three
codons the you AG u AAA or the UGA it
stops the process of translation and the
polypeptide chain is released from the
translation complex so after the
ribosome finishes the protein synthesis
is the protein complete not really after
that the protein is formed it goes
through some additional processing like
some amino acids may be deleted and some
proteins also undergo folding to form a
more stable structure so this was a
brief overlook about the process of
translation guys thank you so much for
watching this video if you found this
video and all the other free educational
videos on this channel helpful you can
now support math simplified on
patreon.com for literally the price for
coffee cup this will allow me to fund my
work and make more videos like this and
we
also unlock some cool patreon only
exclusive content like behind-the-scenes
of these videos upcoming videos early
notifications and exclusive flash cards
and handouts make sure to subscribe us
on YouTube for all the upcoming videos
and also make sure to follow us on
Instagram and Facebook for flash cards
notifications and much more